-Welcome.
Thanks for coming on.
Looking sharp, buddy.
-Thank you very much
for having me, sir.
-Oh, please, I have a lot
to ask you about.
I know that you're
from New York,
but you have a lot of family
in Puerto Rico, right?
-Yes, that's correct.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Yes.
-Puerto Rico.
-I am officially
what is called a Nuyorican.
-Ah.
-Yes, that's me.
-A Nuyorican.
-Exactly. A Nuyorican.
-So you must be familiar
with coquito.
-Oh, of course.
Coquito, yeah.
It's our drink
during the holidays.
-You know coquito?
-Coquito?
-Coquito is my favorite thing.
I was turned on to it,
probably, I don't know,
maybe 10 years ago
or something like that.
And it's my -- it's like
a Puerto Rican eggnog.
-Yeah, like during
the holidays, somewhat.
You know, we have
our certain meals that we have,
and there's definitely going
to be some coquito being --
You know, you're gonna
have that beverage to drink.
It's coconut, rum,
little bit of cinnamon,
and everyone kind of battles out
as who makes the best coquito.
-Yeah, it's always --
it's always mom.
-Of course.
-Yeah, mom, someone's mom
always gives me a bottle.
-Grandma, mom.
-Exactly.
They hook you up with
a homemade bottle of coquito.
-You can't buy it in stores.
-No.
-No. Well, I wanted to welcome
you here to "The Tonight Show."
-What?
-I made us two glasses
of coquito.
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My God.
-Come on.
My friend, come on.
-My God.
Well, okay.
Since we're going there,
we have to do
this Puerto Rican style,
so we have to do
the official toast.
-Oh.
-It goes like this. Follow me.
-Arriba.
-Abajo.
-Al centro.
-Y pa' dentro.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Whoo!
Who made this?
-It's good, right?
-Who made this?
-Someone's mom.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
Now, what do we do?
-Okay. Well --
He's feeling festive.
-Wow!
-I'm gonna make him
Puerto Rican
by the end of this episode.
[ Laughter ]
-I love it.
-We're gonna call him "Jaime."
What about some salsa dancing?
-Oh, no.
-You know how to dance?
-I'm not a good dancer.
I'm gonna ask for some help.
Roots, my brothers, would you
mind helping me out with a
little something, something?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on. Come on.
♪♪
Hey!
All right, here we go.
So you're gonna go forward
with your left,
together,
back with your right.
Nice.
Boom.
Five...four...
Give it up!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh!
You know how to dance, buddy.
Yeah!
You can dance!
-I'm a Puerto Rican boy
raised in a family of women.
I had no choice.
-Yeah! You can dance!
You got the moves.
-They were grabbing me up, man.
Yeah.
-And then here you are,
playing a Southern gentleman,
Will Trent.
-Yes. Yeah.
-How do --
How did you go
and get around doing that?
-I, uh -- well, you know,
one of the first things
I wanted to tackle was, like,
"Okay. This guy's from Atlanta."
You know, I wanted to be
honest about the character.
And so I got a dialect coach
to help take away
some of my New York
Puerto Rican sounds...
-Wow!
-And help me sort of dive into
that molasses, beautiful sound
that's rich in the South.
And so we actually found,
like, a model.
We found --
We'll know this artist
from Outkast, Andre 3000.
We used them
just as an inspiration.
Not trying to copy him,
but to find the nuance
and the specificity of his sound
and try to take some of that
and some of the things
that we put together and create
the sound of Will Trent.
So you listened to Outkast
before you --
-I listened to a bunch of --
Well, I listened to a bunch
of his interviews.
And in those interviews,
I could -- you know,
I was working with this coach,
and we were able to create
this specific sound
that is Will Trent.
-That's amazing.
-Yeah.
Now, every time I watch,
I'm gonna think of Andre 3000.
-I mean, you might pick up
some of it.
It was more like -- it's nice
to have a foundation
that you can base
a dialect on.
So it's not sort of
out of nowhere.
It's very specific.
-Do you have any certain words,
like...
-Well, yeah, they were, like,
phrases, you know,
like the way he walked,
the way he talked.
She was gone when she --
when she was --
she took the dog for a walk
in the morning, and she was --"
You know, so you start
sort of putting together...
-That's right.
-And there's also flow
and a molasses to it,
a jazz to it
that's really beautiful.
So, thank you, Andre 3000,
wherever you at.
-Yeah, that's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A lot of people --
-Excuse me.
-Oh, please. Of course.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people say
in this business...
Ooh, I love coquito.
[ Laughter ]
..."Don't work with children,
and don't work with dogs."
-Yeah.
-They're very difficult --
-Unpredictable. You don't know
what's gonna happen.
-I disagree.
I had a great time with my --
-By the way...
-They were very talented.
-Very talented, very talented.
-What is --
Talk to me about
your co-star here, Betty.
-First of all,
it looks like our prom photo.
[ Laughter ]
It's like graduation,
prom photo.
Betty, she's cute.
She's gonna be offended
that you had other dogs
here tonight with --
You know, and I'm on,
and she didn't get
to show off her tricks.
-Betty, you're invited
for next time Ramon comes on.
-She's amazing.
She's an incredible dog.
She's a diva, you know.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. She rolls with a little
Chihuahua entourage.
There's no eye contact.
She has her own trailer, her own
groomer, her own glam squad.
-Wow.
-She comes to set,
does her scenes very quickly,
and they just --
They fly her in from Florida.
True story.
All the rest of the stuff I like
to just make up about her,
but they actually fly
her in from Florida.
She does a scene,
and they're like constantly
just giving her treats.
And then she's whisked back
to Florida.
And I'm like,
"What did I do wrong in life
that I didn't figure that job?"
-Like, what happens when you
when you finish your take?
-Nothing. They're like, "Cut!
We're moving on."
-Yeah. Yeah. You're like...
-"Got it. We got it."
-"I want a treat
and a flight to Florida."
-Exactly. Yeah, yeah.
-Come on.
-Seriously.
She works for an hour.
-Betty, please, if you're
watching -- I know you are --
please come on the show
next time that Ramon
comes on the show, please.
Thank you, Betty.
-Officially invited.
-You are officially invited.
Can we set up
what "Will Trent's" about,
for anyone who hasn't seen it?
-Yeah, sure.
So, I play Will Trent.
He's a special agent in the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation,
and he's a character
that just had a really
complicated childhood, man.
And what I loved about him
was his resilience.
You know, he's someone that grew
up in the foster-care system,
was an orphan, is dyslexic.
And despite all of these
sort of hurdles in life,
he was able to rise up
the ranks of the GBI.
And he's got a very
unique perspective
as to how he looks at things,
partly because of what
he's been through.
So when he arrives
at a crime scene,
he sort of puts together
the puzzle in his own mind
visually in a very cool way.
And I think that was
some of the fun stuff
visually we get to play with
on the show, too.
-Good man.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Ramon Rodriguez
in "Will Trent." Take a look.
-Is that the last bag of heroin
in Georgia?
-Okay. How do I fix this
for you, Will?
-Go back in time.
Okay?
And don't bring drugs
into my house.
If it's not for you,
then who's it for, huh?
-[ Sighs ]
I can't tell you that.
Look, I had a bad idea,
and I'm over it, but I'm clean.
I'm telling you --
-Tell me!
♪♪
You're lying to me.
And I hate it.
♪♪
Maybe it's a good thing
I'm leaving.
-Yeah, maybe it is.
♪♪
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Next time you come on, pitorro.
-Pitorro. You hear this?
He's saying it live.
He wants pitorro.
For those who don't know,
that's Puerto Rican moonshine.
-Yeah.
-My man wants to party.
-Let's party.
Next time you come back.
Ramon Rodriguez, everybody.
"Will Trent" airs Tuesdays
at 10:00 p.m., on ABC.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break. Stick around.